ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน
เดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันที่ก่อนครับ
คุณนิวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์
ครับค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 ครับค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมครับ
ปีพตอะไรคะอีพ.ต.ต.
2556  5
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ครับค่าแล้วตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้ทาบเวลาแปดโมง 59
นแต่
เช้านะทรายหาอีก 1 นาทีก็จะ 9 โมงแล้วนะ
คะ 9 โมงแล้วตอนนี้
เสร็จ 9:00 นเลยเลย
แล้วตอนนี้เมืองที่ครูหญิงกี่โมงครับ
เรื่องที่คุยอีกเลยนะคะถ้าจะเอาเวลาถ้า
เป็นของคุณนี้ตอนแรกเนี่ยก็คือ
09:59 นะครับ 5 อาหารแต่ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ย
จะ 10 โมงแล้ว
คุณนี้กับเวลาบางทีถ้าเพื่อนคุณนิคถาม
เวลากี่โมงและคุณที่จะชอบพูดแบบ
เกือบหรือแบบให้มันเล็กกลมๆยกตัวอย่าง
เหมือนแบบเออตอนนี้กี่โมงนาฬิกาบอก 8 โมง
52 คุณก็จะบอกก็ 9 โมงแล้วหรือกับอ๊อฟ
08:55 นค่ะจะพูดแบบนั้นไปเลยตัดฮะซึ่งจะ
ทำเลขแบบ 5  10  15  20 น้ำได้ดูแบบเออ
คือตอนแรกคุณนี้ก็ไม่ชินนะเกี่ยวกับเวลา
ว่าแบบทำไมเราต้องมาพูดแบบตัวเลขแบบจริงๆ
เป๊ะๆนั้นน่ะหรือแบบเวลานั่งเครื่องบิน
หรือแบบรถไฟบางทีเขาบอกโอเครถไฟขบวนนี้
ออก 10 โมง 11 นาทีถ้าไม่ต้องมีเหตุ
ทำไมไม่ตั้งให้มันกลมกลมๆว่า 10:10 น
ใช่นั่นแหละคุณมีกันต้องคิดบางทีมึงก็
สั่งดูแปลกๆเห้ใจพี่ก็เคยเจอแบบเนี้ยทำไม
ต้องเป็นเลข 1 ผู้หญิงก็เลยคิดว่าอ๋อเขา
จะออกเนี่ยก็คือคนขึ้นเนี่ยสิบนาทีแต่พอ
11 นาทีปุ๊บที่ไม่ได้แล้วนะฉันจะออกแล้ว
แล้วก็ยก 10 ก็ได้เราก็เข้าใจว่าก็พอจะ
คิดแต่ไม่เคยระบาดอะไรครับมันก็โอเคชาย
ค่ะวันนี้เนี่ยก็ผู้หญิงก็มีคำถามคุณตลกๆ
นะว่าเล่นกับครูนิคคำถามตลกๆได้ใส่งานก็
ว่าแบบเออแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ต้องเป็นคุณนิคจะไม่ต้องคิดว่าจะถูก
หรือจะผิดนะคะว่ามันเป็นคำถามให้ครูนิค
เลือกว่าคือนิอยากจะเลือกอะไรครับแต่ว่า
ทำถามพวกนี้นะคะส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยมันก็คือ
เป็นคำถามที่ว่าไม่ได้เป็นความจริงมัน
เป็นเรื่องที่เราบอกว่ามันเป็นเรื่องที่
มันเป็นไปไม่ได้อยู่แล้วเออในชีวิตจริง
ของเราเนี่ยมันเป็นไปไม่ได้แบบนี้แต่แค่
เอามาเล่นสนุกๆเฉยๆนะคะว่าว่างๆถ้าแบบ
เป็นไปได้เนี่ยครูนิอยากจะเลือกอะไร
ได้เลยนะคะขอร่างนะคะถ้าถ้าเป็นไปได้นะคะ
ครูนิคเนี่ยจะเลือกอะไรระหว่าง
a ครูนิดเนี่ยต้องพูดความจริงตลอดเวลา
ขาด
หรือบีก็กรงเข้ากันโกหกตลอดเวลาเออโอเค
a เนี่ยพูดความจริงลาบีนะพูดโกหก
ต้องอื่นก็คือพูดเรื่องที่พูดเรื่องที่
มันไม่จริงที่มันเป็นเรื่องโกหกตลอดใส่
ค่ะ
คุณนิดเนี่ยจะเลือกพูดความจริงตลอดเวลารอ
เท่าไรอ่ะเอาถ้าเราฟุตบอลจริงคนฟังอ่ะเธอ
เสียใจก็ได้นะไม่สุกโกหกไม่ได้เลยนะเออ
ไม่ตัดคุณนิคเนี่ยคิดว่าถ้าเกิดเราพูด
โกหกตลอดเวลาเนี่ยแล้วถ้าคนนั้นมารู้ที
หลังเมื่อเราคบกับเขาก็รู้สึกไม่ดีอยู่ดี
อ่า
ว่าถ้าเราพูดความจริงตลอดเวลาเนี่ยเราไม่
ต้องมาคิดมากที่หลังว่านี้แล้วเราไม่ต้อง
มาคิดว่าแล้วถ้าเขารู้ให้เออแล้วถ้าเขา
รู้ทีหลังละว่าเราพูดไม่จริงมาอะไรแบบนี้
ครับคุณมีก็เลยคิดว่าถ้าพูดความจริงถึง
มันจะเป็นความจริงที่ทำให้เขารู้สึกเสีย
ใจแต่เขาก็เสียใจต่อนั้นเลยแต่ว่ามันก็
คือความจริงให้ความจริง
แต่ถ้าเราโกหกตอนนั้นเขาฟังแล้วเขารู้สึก
ดีว่าเราโกหกแต่พออาทิตย์ต่อไปเขารู้ว่า
เราโกหกเขาก็เสียใจเหมือนกันแค่มันเสียใจ
ตอนนี้กับเสียใจกิน
ก็เลยเลือกเลยเลือกก็ไม่ได้ก็เลยว่าพูด
เพราะอุ้ยดีกว่านั่ง 15 ให้ชัดในท้ายอ่ะ 8
5 เป็นครูหญิงผู้หญิงจะเลือกอะไร
ผู้หญิงก็เลือกยากเหมือนกันนะจะคุยก็คิด
ว่า
ก็พูดความจริงดีกว่านะด้วยความจริงตลอด
รู้สึกว่าถ้าเราโกหก
มันเหนื่อยเออ
ใช่แค่นั้นแหละเออถ้าเราโกหกมันก็จะ
เหนื่อยหน่อยนะถึงแม้ว่าถ้าเราเลือกแล้ว
เราต้องพูดโกหกโกหกตลอดแต่เราก็ยังรู้สึก
ว่ามันจึงในสมองเรามาจะอัตโนมัติอ่ะต่อ
ไม่ติดโกหกแต่มันก็เหนื่อยก็เลยคิดว่าเธอ
พูดความจริงดีกว่ามันครูนิคใช่พูดถึงการ
โกหกเนี่ยอันนี้คุณก็เพิ่งรู้
เมื่อ 2 3ปีที่แล้วว่ามันมีการโกหกที่
เขาเรียกว่าถ้าจริงๆไม่มีภาษาไทยแต่ถ้า
แปลเดี๋ยวเขาจะเรียกว่าคืนโกหกสีขาว
และขอไว้ลายอ่ะอ่ะใช่แต่สำหรับคุณนี้กะ
คุณนี้ก็คิดว่าไว้ลายเนี่ยหรือโกหกสีขาว
เนี่ยคุณคิดว่ามันก็
มันก็ยังคิดว่าเป็นการโกหกอยู่ดีถึงมันจะ
ไม่ติดแย่มาก
เป็นสีเทาแล้วไม่ขาวขนาดนั้นมีข่าวแหละ
เออมันก็คือโกหกเหมือนกันแต่คือมันแค่ว่า
พูดเพื่อให้คนสั่งรู้สึกดีแล้วเมื่อเขา
รู้ทีหลังเนี่ยมันก็ไม่ได้รู้สึกอะไรมาก
เพราะเหมือนจะขึ้นเหมือนเราทำเรามีความ
คิดว่าเราหวังดีกับเขาเราก็ต้องโกหกแต่
มันจะไม่ได้เรื่องใหญ่โตชาย
ที่ไข่เนาะก็ขอที่ 2 นะคะคุณนี้ถ้าเลือก
ได้น้อยถ้าเป็นไปได้นะคะคุณนิจะเลือกอะไร
ระหว่างพูด
ก็ได้นะพูดไม่ได้อีกเลย
หรือ
ต้องพูดทุกอย่างที่คิดคือค่อยคิดอะไร
เนี่ยปากเราจะพูดเลยครับพรุ่งนี้จะเลือก
อะไรคะระหว่างพูดไม่ได้เลยหรือหรือพูดทุก
อย่างที่คิดอ่ะ
คุณนิดระหว่างพูดไม่ได้เลย
กับ
พูดทุกอย่างที่คิดเนี่ยครูนิคจะเลือกพูด
ไม่ได้เลย
ทำไมอ่ะแต่ก็นี้จะพูดได้เลยนะอยากบอกอะไร
ก็พูดไม่ได้แล้วนะครับพรุ่งนี้คิดว่าคืน
นี้คิดว่าถ้าพูดไม่ได้เลยเนี่ยสำหรับคุณ
นิดเนี่ยโอเค
ไม่ต้องพูดก็ได้ใช่ไหมทุกวันอยากได้เนาะ
เออเขียนก็ได้หรือก็คนนี้คิดว่าถ้าตัวคุณ
นิกพูดทุกอย่างที่คุณมิตรคลิปเนี่ยมีพระ
คุณเด็กรูปภาพคุณอีกแล้วเป็นคนชอบคิดอะไร
ที่มันแปลกๆหรือที่มันไร้สาระตัวเองแล้ว
บางทีเนี่ยเราพูดไปคนที่ฟังเราเนี่ยเขาจะ
แบบอะไรวะพูดอะไรอีกแล้วใช่ก็เลยเลือกที่
ไม่พูดไม่ได้เลยดีกว่า
เข้าใจเข้าใจแล้วถ้าเป็นครูหญิงหล่ะโอโห้
บ่อยากอยู่นะแต่ว่าฟังครูนี้อีกแล้วนะคะ
ดึกแล้วคิดว่าเออเรื่องพูดไม่ได้เลยดี
กว่าเหมือนกัน
ว่าครับเพราะว่าคุยรู้สึกว่าถ้าเราพูดทุก
อย่างที่คิดบางครั้งถ้าเราคุยกับสวรรค์
คุยกับแม่คุยกับเพื่อนอย่างเงี้ยแล้วบาง
ครั้งอาจจะคิดอะไรเกี่ยวกับเพื่อนอยู่ที่
มันไม่โอเคอ่ะเราก็จะพูดมาเลยอ่ะคะคนฟัง
เขาก็ต้องเสียใจ
คะแล้วก็อาจจะเสียใจเลยคิดว่าเธอพูดไม่
ได้ดีกว่าที่นี้คนนี้มีคำถามว่าสำหรับผู้
หญิงเนี่ย
เอ่อพูดทุกอย่างที่คิดกับพูดความจริงตลอด
คิดว่าเหมือนกันไหม
ผู้หญิงที่ว่าไม่เหมือนนะเออเพราะว่า
เราพูดความจริงแต่ความจริงที่เราพูดอ้ะ
เราคิดมาแล้วไงคะว่าเราจะพูดยังไงให้คุณ
ฟังไม่ได้แบบคือบางอย่างอ่ะความคิดของเรา
เราไม่ได้อยากพูดออกมาเออใช่ใช่มั้ยกูจะ
คิดเหมือนกันนะว่ามันไม่เหมือนกันใช่เออ
คนนี้ตอนแรกเนี่ยตอนแรกคุณนี้คิดว่าเฮ้ย
จริงๆก็เหมือนกันแต่ Top คิดคิดๆมากกว่า
นี้นะก็คิดว่าเออมันก็ไม่เหมือน
ใช่ก็พูดทุกอย่างที่คิดเนี่ยจริงๆพูดทุก
อย่างที่คิดมันไม่ได้แปลว่าไอ้สิ่งที่เรา
คิดนะนี่คือความจริงหรือเปล่าใช่เพราะว่า
มันแค่แบบเราคิดอะไรสมให้คุณเห็นคนนี้
อย่างเงี้ยตัวผู้หญิงคิดนะวิตัดผมใหม่ไม่
โอเคเลยเฮ้ยไม่จำเป็นต้องพูดก็ได้เดี๋ยว
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้โกหกนะคะตัวครูนิคไม่ได้ถาม
ให้แต่สักอยู่ตบกูทุกอย่างที่เฮ็ด
ตัดผมมาไม่ดีเลยนะเราก็ไม่ได้ถาม
เออเอ้ยมันก็เป็นเรื่องที่เออใช่ๆๆจริง
ข้อต่อไปนะคะคู่นี้ถ้าเป็นไปได้อะไรคะคุณ
ที่จะเลือกอะไรระหว่าง
1 น้องก็คือสระผมได้ปีละ 1 ครั้งเท่า
นั้น
หรือ 2 นะคะต้องใส่ถุงเท้าที่เปียกถุง
เท้าน้องจะใส่รองเท้ามันก็จะไปถุงเท้าใช่
ไหมคะใส่ถุงเท้าที่ปอยู่ตลอดชีวิต
ใหญ่ๆๆอันแรกคือสระผมปีละ 1 ครั้งใช้หา
ที่สองคือใส่ถุงเท้าที่เปรียบเปียก
ที่ดวงอยู่ในรองเท้าแล้วก็ถุงเท้าที่แบบ
เปียกมีน้ำคนนี้เรื่องอะไรโคนิคจะเลือก
สระผมปีละ 1 ครั้งทำไมอ่ะ
คืนคือจริงๆคนนี้ก็คิดว่าอาจจะเป็นเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรที่โกงหรือเปล่าถ้าคุณคิดว่า
สาปผมปีละ 1 ครั้งคุณนี้ก็โกนหัวก็ได้
แต่ถ้าจะต้องใส่ถุงเท้าที่มันเปียกแล้ว
อยู่ในรองเท้าตลอดชีวิตเนี่ยนั้นมันไม่
โอเคเพราะเธอเห็นเรา
ไม่รู้สิคนนี้คิดว่ามันสกปรกอ้ะมันเหม็น
แล้วมันอาจจะมีเชื้อราไหม
เพราะว่าเราจะบอกว่าจุ๊ GOT7 รองเท้าที่
ไม่ใส่ที่ไม่ต้องใส่ถุงเท้าสิดีแต่บาง
ครั้งบางงานจนยิ่งคนนี้เป็นผู้ชายเนาะ
หลายๆชุดมันคือผู้หญิงอย่างผู้หญิงเนี่ย
รองเท้าบางอย่างไม่ต้องใส่ถุงเท้าก็ได้ไง
หรือบางทีถ้าของผู้หญิงเนี่ยเขาจะใส่ถุง
น่องมันก็บางนะมันเปียกไม่ได้รู้สึกอะไร
เนอะๆจะคนไทยอ่ะจริงๆก็บางคนน่ะใส่ถุง
เท้าแล้วก็ใส่รองเท้าแตะนะอิอิ
แม่คุณอิ๊กเป็นพวกเขากลัวดำเค้าตรวจแล้ว
ดำ
ใช่ทั้งหมดแล้วแบบเธอใส่ไม่ใส่รถถุงเท้า
มันก็ตัวดำเป็นอาเซนใช่ไหมดำวายของรอง
เท้าตลกมากกว่าอย่างไงเออข่าวคนนี้ก็เลย
คิดว่าใช่ตากผมปีละ 1 ครั้งน่ะคือ
มีเพราะว่าเหมือนกับคุณนิกลัวด้วยว่าถ้า
ใส่ถ้าต้องใส่ถุงเท้าที่เปียกตลอดชีวิต
เนี่ยคือคุณเล็กเคยเห็นเวลาเราอยู่ในน้ำ
นานๆแล้วมือมันเปื่อยเท้ามันเปื่อยอ่ะ
เออใช่แค่คิดถึงกลิ่นก็ไม่ไหวแล้วค่ะคุณ
นี่แหละ
กินก็ไม่โอเคแล้วเพลง
ได้กับข้อต่อไปนะคะพรุ่งนี้อันนี้เนี่ย
อ่าไม่รู้คนนี้เคยดูหรือเปล่านะมันเป็น
ซีรีส์นะคะมีก็คือจะให้ครูนิกต้องไปแบบ
ให้ชีวิตจริงๆของเราในทุกวันนี้นะคะให้
เราเหมือน series  2 เรื่องนี้เหมือนเรา
อยู่ในซีรีส์แต่ช่วงนี้ล่ะก็คือคือ 1  The
Walking  Dead
ก็คือ Walking ๆก็คือมีสองบี้เนาะเราต้อง
วิ่งหนีซอมบี้นั้นก็คือเหมือนเปลี่ยนเลย
ว่าโลกนี้มีซอมบี้แล้วเราต้องวิ่งหนี
ซอมบี้แล้วต้องไปอยู่ในเรื่อง The
Walking  Dead หรือเราต้องไปอยู่ใน
เรื่อง American คอนเสร์ตอรี่เออโอเค
อเมริกันฮอเรอร์สตอรี่นี่น่าจะเป็นเกี่ยว
กับคืออันนั้นจะเริ่มกับชายก็เหมือนกับมี
มีค่ามีมีคนตายหรือแบบฆ่าคนหรือ
มันก็จะมีเกี่ยวกับผี
ปีศาจแบบนี้ครับวันนี้จะเลือกอยู่ใน
เรื่องไหนคะมีชีวิตอยู่ในเรื่องไหนคุณนิค
เอ่อ A คือ Walking  Dead  The  Walking
ได้ไม่ชอบเราก็ดีนะเป็นน้ำมันมีปัญหาเหรอ
สตอรี่คุณนิดแต่เลือก The  Walking  Dead
ทำไมอ่ะคือคุณนิกะห์จริงๆคุณนิคชอบ
American  Horror  Story
คุณชอบซอมบี้ๆว่าคือจริงๆชอบซอมบี้มั้ย
แต่พวกหนังที่มันมีซอมบี้คุณนี่ก็เคยดูคน
อื่นชอบคือคือคนที่คิดว่าเอ่อ The
Walking  Dead เนี่ยมันเราสามารถใช้
ชีวิตอยู่ง่ายกว่าก็อยู่ได้กว่าอเมริกัน
ฮอเรอร์สตอรี่ใช่เพราะว่าอันนั้นมาเขาจะ
มีเกี่ยวกับพวกผีปีศาจหรือเวทมนตร์พวกเม
ติกและผมให้รักคุณนิคคิดว่ามันมันมัน
ทรมานกว่ามันน่ากลัวมากกว่ากลัวแล้วมันจะ
เรามันดีความทุกข์ดีกว่าใช่ครับถ้า The
Walking  Dead เนี่ยเราก็หนีซอมบี้หรือ
สู้กับซอมบี้แล้วถ้าเราโดนซอมบี้กินหรือ
การ์ดเนื้อมันก็ตายเราก็จบถึงแดงอเมริกัน
เค้ารถ Sorry เราอาจจะมีตายใช่ไหมเราจะ
โดนจับไปแล้วก็แบบไม่ให้ไม่ให้กินข้าวไม่
ให้ดื่มน้ำตอนนี้โสดเมื่อไหร่ฉันจะตาย
เมื่อไหร่ประมาณมันบ่โอ้ยมึงกลับมันเป็น
แบบนี้มาหลายวันแล้วมันเจ็บมันปวดเมื่อ
ไหร่จะจบซะ
วันนี้ก็ไม่ชอบฉันจริงเดิด
ก็ต่อไปนะคะคุณเด็กอ้าถ้าให้คุณอีกเลือก
ได้เนาะคุณนิจะเลือกอะไรระหว่าง
หนึ่งก็คือคุณนิดเนี่ยต้องสะอึกๆ
ครับสะอึกตลอดทางคุณแม่เขาจบ 2  2 ก็
คือมันเหมือนกับว่าเราจะจำใช่ไหมแบบก็คือ
การจะจามแต่ไม่เอาจำนะเหมือนเราแบบจะจาม
อ่ะกับ
แต่ไม่จามครับตลอดชีวิตเออเลือกอันไหน
เออ A คือสะอึกชีวิตบีนิคเออร์เหมือนจะ
จาน
ตลอดตายคุณนิคจะเลือกบี่
หาทำไมคะอันนี้จริงอันนี้เป็นเด้ออันนี้
เป็นเรื่องจริงนิดหน่อยว่า
คุณนี้กะเวลาจานคุณนิคจะชอบห้ามตัวเองไม่
ให้จาม
แล้ว
คืนนี้ก็เลยอ่ะเออมันก็ง่ายนะโทรศัพท์
นะเนี่ยเวลาคนที่สะอึกคือนิดไม่ชอบเพราะ
เบิดวันนี้เคยเหมือนกับสะอึกแบบครึ่งวัน
น่ะ
อันดับมันเหนื่อยอ่ะอีกละเราเวลาพอเราจะ
พูดมันสะอึกมันเหนื่อยแต่ถ้าจะชักมัน
เหนื่อยนะงั้นมันเหมือนก็เป็นไปอีกแล้ว
ถ้าจะจามเนี่ยมันก็
คุณที่จะอาจจะอาจจะโรคจิตนิดหน่อยแต่แค่
พอมาเจอตามแล้วคนนี้เจอเหมือนกับภูเก็ต
ตัวจ่าเออไม่จำเกือบแบบแป๊บนึงแป๊บนึง
โอเค
วันนี้ก็ไม่ได้รู้สึกว่าแบบการที่เราจะ
จามแล้วเหมือนมันไม่จำเนี่ยเออมันไม่ได้
แบบยากอะไรใช่มั้ยไม่ได้เป็นรู้สึกไม่ได้
เป็นความรู้สึกที่แบบว่าอุ้ยทำไมคือบางคน
นั้นแบบไม่จามจำไม่ออกไปรู้สึกว่ะไม่ได้
เลยเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนอ่ะคนนี้ก็ทำไม่ได้
พี่ขอโทษกันเริ่มทำได้ขึ้นไปเถอะเออมันก็
ดีเหมือนกันนะ
นี่อาจจะลูกศิษย์นิดหน่อยแล้วก็
เหมือนกับเวลาอีกครั้งอีกอย่างนึงครับก็
คือเวลาคุณเล็กคันคอแล้วจะอาลัยมันก็จะมี
บางครั้งที่คือเด็กเหมือนกันห้ามตัวเอง
ไม่ให้อายอ่ะ
ฉันมากกว่าเดิมใช่ไหมรักที่นี้เนี่ยพอมัน
คันมากมันก็จะถึงจุดที่แบบมันพร้อมมึง
ต้อง I อ่านมากแล้วมันจะไปอ๋อคนนี้ก็เลย
คิดว่ารับคนนี้ก็คิดว่าพอเราทำแบบนั้นได้
อ้ะมันจะอายน้อยลงสำหรับคุณนิคนักเออแล้ว
มันก็เลยคิดว่าเขาคงเป็นเหมือนกับจามและ
แต่จริงๆอ่ะเขาบอกว่าตามถ้าเรามากะห้าม
ตัวเองไม่ให้จานเนี้ยทอมมันจะจามอีกกับ
มันจะมากกว่าเดิม
[เพลง]
ใช่วันนี้ก็เลยจำต้องข้ามตัวเองไว้ไม่ให้
จะและอีกแล้วได้เออปรับตั้งที่มันก็ไม่
ได้ทุกครั้งนะเพราะว่าผ่านคือมันเป็นเป็น
เขาเรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะถ้ายกตัวอย่างง่ายๆ
เหมือนเวลาน้ำอัดลมอ่ะ
กระจุกเหมือนไปอาจจะอยู่ตรงสาทร 5 มัน
เรื่อยๆมันก็ยิ่งเพิ่มมากขึ้นมากขึ้นจน
มันเบียดกันเข้ามาแล้วก็เราเปิดปุ๊บมันก็
ก็เหมือนเหมือนตามของครูดิใช่
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ค่อยข้อนึงนะค่อยข้างหนึ่งเข้าสุดท้ายให้
อ่ะ
สมมุติว่าให้เลือกนะคะก็เป็นไปได้เนาะข้อ
ที่ 1 เวลาคุณนี้ไปเข้าห้องน้ำแล้วให้ใช้
กระดาษทรายครับกระดาษทรายนะเหล็กครับตลาด
นี้นะคะก็จะสายที่ไว้ขัดกระดาษทรายแทน
ทิชชู่
ปกติเราใส่ทิชชูใช่ไหมคะก็ไม่ใช้ทิชชูจะ
ได้ใช้กระดาษทรายนะคะหรือว่าบีนะดีเนี่ย
ถ้าให้เราใช้ Hot  Sauce ซอสซอสคือ
x แต่ว่ามันใช่จริงๆจริงๆมันเหมือนกับ
ซอสพริกครับแต่ว่ามันจะเป็นน้ำมากกว่ามาก
กว่าๆนั่นแหละข้อสอบให้ใช้ Hot  Sauce
ชอบแชนยาหยอดตาไหมบางคนเนี่ยใส่
คอนแทคเลนส์แล้วแล้วแบบตาแห้งก็ต้องหยอด
ตานะแต่ให้ใช้ Pot  source หยอดตาแทนวัน
นี้จะเลือกอะไรระหว่างใช้กระดาษทรายแทน
ทิชชู่หรือไซส์คอร์ส source แทนยาหยอดตา
คิดนาน
คิดนานเพราะกำลังคิดว่าอันไหนมันจะเจ็บ
มากกว่า
เออ
A คือกระดาษตายแทนทิชชูข้อดีคือ Hot
Sauce แท่งใหญ่หยดตาใจค่ะ
คุณนิดจะจะเลือกกระดาษทรายทิชชู่
ก็คุณนิคอันนี้แค่คนนี้คิดว่าตามันสำคัญ
มากกว่า
สอนเนี่ยตาเราอาจจะบอกเรามองไม่เห็นอีก
เลย
สายๆแล้วพอตอนนั้นเนี่ยพอมองไม่เห็นเลย
เนี่ยเราจะหยิบของมั่วแล้ว
มันจะใช้อะไรก็ไม่รู้แล้วกินอะไรก็ไม่รู้
แล้วแต่ถ้าเป็นกระดาษทรายและไม่อยากจะ
เจ็บหน่อยแต่มันก็แค่ก็เราจะไงเดี่ยวจะ
ใช่
ก็เลยคิดว่ามันใช้ชีวิตง่ายกว่าถ้าเลือก
กระดาษทรายดอกโอเคอะนั่นแหละค่ะก็เป็น
เกมส์สนุกๆนะแล้วก็เป็นนักเรียนและนัก
เรียนมาเล่นเป็นพร้อมกับครูนิคได้นะคะว่า
นักเรียนเรียกอะไรน้ำแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้
เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วคิดว่าผู้หญิงกับคุณนี้
ก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะไปแล้วโอเคได้แล้วไปเจอ
กันใหม่ครับสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ